hello everyone and thank you for joining
me today
this is data leaders at the helm
and in this session we're going to take
a look at how technologies and workplace
environments are evolving
and how these changes are turning data
leaders into an emerging force
and are placing them in a unique
position to really chart a path forward
for their organizations my name is pedro
arellano and i'm head of
product marketing for looker at google
cloud
those of you familiar with looker may
have noticed that we have a new logo
it's very exciting we are now part of
google cloud
uh local's mission statement which is to
empower people
through the smarter use of data actually
aligns
very very well with google's mission
statement which is all about organizing
the world's information
and making it universally accessible and
useful
um another thing that looker and google
cloud share in common is that we are
absolutely committed
to investing in multi-cloud and that's a
common theme that you'll hear
throughout the sessions this week
just a bit of quick context about where
the looker product stands today
today there are more than 5 000
developers all
building on top of the looker platform
we have more than 2
000 companies all over the world using
looker
from the largest retailers and banks all
the way down to one to two person
startups
and something that will be pretty
central to today's talk and other local
sessions you attend this week
half of our customers are using looker
to work with data
in a way that goes beyond traditional bi
now before we get started i do want to
take a moment to state today's goals
first my goal is to hopefully you
understand that the value of
data within an organization is no longer
up for debate
everybody needs data and everybody's job
has the potential to be improved with
data
second there are three trends that we're
going to identify
and explore in this presentation and
these trends will help put into context
how we've arrived at
this particular moment of such great
potential for data
and finally we want you as data leaders
to significantly uh
understand that almost regardless of
your title
you're now in a position to really
influence the direction of your
of your organization like never before
so uh hopefully this is why you've
decided to join this session today
uh and it will help you better equip
yourself with knowledge
uh and help you grow as a data leader in
your organization
and also to connect further with the
data community
so uh let's get started let's get right
to the heart of the presentation i'm
going to start by highlighting three
trends
that are contributing to the success of
looker entrance that we believe
every data professional should be aware
of to maximize their own potential
the first trend is that everybody needs
data and that everybody at an
organization can benefit from it
in fact i would argue that more so than
everybody needs data
everybody expects data so why is that
well let's take a look at this stat from
idc and idc research paper it shows
that the world's data is expected to
reach 175
zettabytes by the year 2025
and just to put that figure in
perspective if each gigabyte in a
zettabyte or a brick
we would have enough bricks to build the
great wall of china
258 times i mean that's just a
staggering figure it's a massive
explosion of data
but what exactly is driving this growth
what's driving this demand for data
what's driving this demand is that there
uh there are the
the data hungry workforce as we call it
has arrived
think about it today there are all these
job titles that didn't even exist 10
years ago
jobs whose entire purpose is to work
with data
and deliver data across an organization
and there are so many roles that simply
can't function
without data quantitative marketers
devops engineers
data-driven product managers 10 years
ago you still needed to convince your
executive team of how much data matters
how
important it is to be able to push the
organization forward
and how transformative it can be but the
demand for data
is now such that it's created all these
job titles around data
you have digital marketers who can be
way more effective
on managing their spend using very
innovative applications like
automated bots that automatically
increase or decrease
bids on online ads depending on the
performance of those ads
you have product managers who can better
understand product usage
uh and they can use that understanding
to know where they need to invest time
and where they need to invest
development efforts and also spot
opportunities for expansion
but despite this growing demand for data
across organizations
we still find that 66 of companies
two-thirds of companies are still using
spreadsheets for the majority of their
analytics
which which begs the question is this
the best way is our spreadsheets really
the best way
to reach people within an organization
using data
are the tools that we're using today the
right ones to reach these this
data-driven workforce
this data-hungry workforce and the
market has clearly answered this
question and that leads us to trend
number two
turn number two is that sas businesses
sas business and consumer applications
are
absolutely exploding and and yes this is
contributing to the massive growth in
data volumes
but it's also creating new ways to reach
people with data
so think about it how many sas
applications have you used just today
and just doing a quick count
i started my day on gmail and google
calendar
i used google chat to message my team i
reviewed my presentation
and my notes in google docs and google
slides
i've used applications to look at our
customer crm data
i used another application to understand
the marketing funnel
so by the end of the day i'll probably
have used more than 20 sas
applications and what's interesting that
each of these
applications is actually a data
application it's generating data
it's crunching data it's feeding me data
in some way
now to give you some context the looker
team we use more than 40 sas
applications to run our business but the
average
enterprise uses over 1 000 sas
applications and that number continues
to grow every year
now as i said all these applications are
data applications they are data powered
products it's basically a user
experience built on top of reserve data
and and their goal is to reduce user
friction
when accessing data and when asking
insights
and make the whole experience with data
a lot better and a lot easier
so i'll give you a couple of examples if
you're a digital marketer
your job is already made better it's
enhanced
by using google ads if you're working
with crm data
you use probably using salesforce
salesforce is an enormously popular crm
system and these products are trying to
make data way more accessible
to to help people in the organization
get their job done
but it does come with challenges because
these products they're very good but
they're
they're typically very good for one
particular use case they're designed for
a specialized use queso
for example you probably wouldn't use
zendesk to analyze your advertising
performance
in the same way that you wouldn't use
salesforce to track and manage your help
desk tickets
uh so these applications already very
powerful but that means that they're
also very
isolated and and you have to jump from
application to application to really do
your job and
what that means is that you end up
missing insights
and you end up missing opportunities
that are only
uncovered when you're able to connect
the data and which allows you to see the
complete picture
so when every department gets a
specialized sas application like this it
means that you start seeing islands of
departmental data start appearing
the sales team for example will use one
set of apps like use salesforce and a
few other apps
marketing will do the same thing they'll
use google ads they use marketo and
something
else the product team will use yet
another set of apps and so on and so
forth
across the organization you see this
happening
the problem here is that each department
has its own
island of data they have their own silo
of data but they're all disconnected
from each other
and they could all potentially have a
different
and even conflicting understanding of
critical business metrics
that should in theory be shared across
the organization
and everybody should have a common
understanding about them
so data professionals we we refer to
this as a
as an analytics governance problem but
it is a very
big problem it's a bigger problem than
that because it's also a value problem
because the fundamental value of
business intelligence a fundamental
belief that we all share
is that connecting data makes it way
more valuable
and and that it's only with connected
data that we get a better understanding
and a more comprehensive view
of how a business really functions
now this problem i'm afraid is only
going to get worse it's going to get
tougher to solve
according to idc within the next three
years 500 million
new business apps will be created so
if we think that the this is a tough
problem now if we think it's hard to
organize data now
it's only going to get harder it's going
to get harder a lot faster
so the question is what do we do
well something has to change according
to forrester
over 80 percent of structured data isn't
analyzed
and that's really unfortunate because it
means that over time
we're losing valuable insights and and
we're losing the opportunity to benefit
from connected data
but fortunately there is hope and that
hope is trend number three
data infrastructure is rapidly evolving
so data engineering technologies have
really come a long way they've changed
dramatically in the last few years
and and they've really raised the level
of analytics and insights there
that are achievable if i think back of
when i started my career you know more
than 20 years ago
the the technologies that were that were
considered the gold standard
then uh have are so so different
to to what we have today um the the
first set of of those technologies
is modern cloud databases databases like
bigquery
like snowflake even some of the aws
offerings these are
bigger faster cheaper databases where
you can store
massive amounts of data you can query
the data at a much lower cost
you can do it at a much higher level of
performance than these platforms of you
know years years past
but these databases are also getting
smarter you're seeing things like
augmented analytics
machine learning and other technologies
that automatically generate insights
and are and are integrated directly into
the database
the second thing you're seeing is that
once you have your data stored in a
modern cloud database
you can now take a more modern approach
to integrating and managing the data
and this modern approach doesn't depend
on physical data extracts
and it can transform data on the fly and
it's called elt
elt basically takes the traditional idea
of etl
and flips it on its head it makes the
management of the data ecosystem
a lot simpler a lot more flexible a lot
more agile
and you're going to find with this
approach that you'll need fewer data
extracts you'll be able to access data
in real time
you'll be able to access complete row
level data
your updates your data updates are going
to be simpler and a lot faster
but here's the key what enables this new
elt approach what makes it possible
is the growing importance of modeled
data
and what i mean by that is the the
ability to use
or or deploy a semantic model that
describes
all of your company's data a semantic
model that defines all of your business
logic
and with looker you use a technology
that we call look amel for your semantic
modeling
what's great about looking mel is that
it's a highly collaborative technology
and it allows tens or even hundreds of
data engineers to work together
on the same semantic model and what this
does is that it enables
real data teams as opposed to having
individuals
off on their own doing shadow i.t
so it's a very exciting time to work in
these in this industry
these data engineering technologies or
these advancements in data engineering
technologies
are really changing our world and our
lives as data professionals and
and uh they're they're allowing us to
bring much more data to the cloud
they're making it faster and easier to
deploy different types of data
and as i said they really allow your
workforce to to um
to work collaboratively and at scale
now let me show you a glimpse of how
quickly some of these cloud data
technologies are being adopted
what you're seeing here is a view across
looker's customer base
that shows the growth of different
database technologies so
you can see some of the classic database
technologies like postgres
and my sql and you know they're still
being used but if you pay attention to
the modern platforms like bigquery and
snowflake
the growth that we're seeing with those
technologies is just absolutely
remarkable
so if part of your motivation for
attending the session is that your
company is considering
making a transition or an investment in
a cloud database
now is the time to do that gartner says
that within the next three years 75
of all databases in existence will be
hosted in the cloud
and one of the main reasons for that
phenomenal growth of the cloud is the
ability to leverage
and manage data at the scale required
today
so with those three trends in mind let's
let's wrap up this section with a
description of what we think success
with data looks like
the first criteria is that data needs to
be complete and it needs to be
trustworthy
there needs to be confidence in the data
people need to be able to trust the
insights that your data platform is
delivering
we talk to companies all the time who
don't trust the data that their platform
is delivering because there's no
consistent business logic
across the thousands of workbook books
or spreadsheets or reports
that are being used by their employees
so what happens is that
instead of having productive
conversations about the data
you end up arguing over whose numbers
are correct
and in order to restore that trust
what's needed
is a centralized and reusable semantic
modeling layer
something like what lookers look at male
technology provides that allows everyone
to work with the same definition
of key business logic so there's never
ever any ambiguity
over what the data means there is only
one definition of customer there is only
one calculation for profit
there's only one definition of revenue
for example and everybody's speaking the
same language
the second criteria is that data should
be near real time
and that's really what modern cloud
databases allow us to do today
they make near real-time insights a
reality
and think of how valuable this is really
for any industry but to take retailers
for example imagine if retailers could
optimize
their digital advertising spend in real
time during the holiday shopping season
it's just
massively valuable the third criteria
is that data should not just have an
analytical purpose
it should also have an operational
purpose and this is a
really big departure from the way that
we've come to
think of data traditionally it means
that the
insights that your data platform is
generating should have the potential to
trigger
actions and the reason is that modern
business users don't just want to
understand the data they want to be able
to use data
to get something done to take some kind
of action
what that means is that we finally have
to actually
go beyond dashboards in the way that we
use data
data should feed other systems it should
feed
other machines to help people get real
work done to help drive the business
forward
it should not be used just to display it
on our report so let's take a look at a
few examples of how this actually works
in the real world
the first example is a company called
salesloft salesloft is a prospecting and
customer engagement platform based in
atlanta
and their customer success team monitors
customer health scores
and these scores look at product usage
and alert the customer success team of
any potential issues
early on now unfortunately this
information has to be manually
monitored and manually looked up
in order to catch low scores before
risking a customer churning
what they've done is now they've
replaced this manual system with an
automated system that they built using
looker so they combine
looker with the sales platform so
that when a customer health score drops
below a certain threshold
an alert automatically notifies the
customer success manager
of that problem and then automatically
triggers an
email within their engagement platform
to start re-engaging with that customer
this is massively valuable for uh for
sales loft it increases the relevance of
their customer communications it
increases the impact
of their customer communications and it
ultimately creates a better customer
experience
and and notice how this use case isn't
about showing
numbers on a graph or on a dashboard but
it's still an immensely valuable
data-driven application and just how
valuable well this application helped
sales staff
preserve 1.2 million dollars in arr
in the first four months alone
another example is car next door car
next door is a car sharing company in
australia
the car next door team was already using
looker they were getting value from
liquor
across a number of different areas
optimizing marketing delivering faster
support
more efficient product development but
then they used liquor in a way that was
pretty unexpected
um last year there were some pretty
severe hail storms that hit parts of
australia
and these storms caused really serious
damage to many of car next door's
vehicles
and of course as you can imagine this
resulted in higher repair
costs insurance losses from damaged
vehicles that they had to take out of
service
that also uncovered potentially risks
should something like this happen again
so
in order to reduce future downtime and
future losses
uh and to be able to continue delivering
an excellent customer experience
the car next door team quickly developed
a new application using looker
that would help them prepare for future
it weatherings so they do is that they
use liquor geospatial capabilities
and that allows them to identify cars
that are in locations that are
associated with weather events
and in combination with other
technologies like segment
and brays they can send alerts to
drivers to help them get to safety
so this is another example of using data
in a way that does not involve
displaying it on a report or on a
dashboard
but it does help card next door identify
at-risk cars
and at-risk drivers and it improves the
reliability of the service and improves
the customer experience too
and all of this is powered by look
finally an example that anybody in sales
will relate to
this is about slack slack has a product
that they built called midas
touch the problem that the midas touch
tool solves
is that their sales reps were spending
many many hours
every single week creating customer
slide decks so they were
building these decks by hand by
literally copying and pasting content
from their bi tool into google slides
this is very time consuming work it's
very repetitive
it's very prone to errors so of course
it's a perfect candidate for automation
so um they envisioned the midas tool the
midas touch tool excuse me at its core
as integration between slack and
salesforce and looker
and google slides and what the midas
touch tool does
is it allows the sales reps in slack to
search for customers
communicating with salesforce and then
request
a set of pre-populated personalized
slides
for that customer with data that's
pulled from looker
all without leaving slack so this means
that a sales rep can generate a
personalized report
for every single customer and every
single customer meeting that they go
into
with a single command as you can imagine
it makes them look like heroes
in every meeting that they go to and
it's a really interesting example
because it's such a great story of how
data can be used from multiple different
departments and can be brought together
in order to massively amplify the
experience for every customer
now these customer examples show how the
three trends that we reviewed earlier
are
all converging to create many great
opportunities for companies
to really build different kinds of data
experiences and for data leaders to
influence the the
their companies to drive their companies
in this direction
now when i see data leaders what does
that mean what is a data leader
well data leaders have lots of different
job titles the obvious ones like chief
data officer
head of analytics the vp of bi a data
analyst data engineer
but they can also be people that don't
necessarily have a data or analytics
title like a line of business leader
essentially anybody who can help shape
the data strategy for their organization
no matter the title these are the people
that are tasked with
creating a data culture and that means
that incorporating data
into not just our work lives but also
our personal lives
so you can see the examples of these
modern businesses that i shared
these data leaders are the ones who are
driving the company forward
uh and and that leads us to this idea
that data leadership
today really is business leadership
so the key is to find new use cases for
data
use cases that fall outside of the
conventional understanding of bi
this is a very interesting quote from
forester that talks about how leading
companies
are are thinking about data and how they
are driving growth
through differentiating experiences
products and services experiences
products and services it's really
interesting and what i find fascinating
about this quote
is that it talks about the value the
data can provide
but nowhere does it use terms like
analytics
or reporting or dashboards and the idea
is that data is no longer something that
is used exclusively for the purpose of
analyzing it on charts and graphs
data is now something that can be
infused into everyday business processes
that can
fuel operational workflows it can be
used to build new products to market it
can be used to make people smarter
to optimize your operations to create
new revenue streams
and and this is very exciting because
what we're talking about is expanding
the idea of traditional bi and really
bringing it into the modern era the era
of data-driven experiences
so what can you do as a data leader to
initiate this change within your
organization and to bring your company
into this
era of data driven experiences
well first of all think of modern data
technologies
think of your current technology stack
what are the technologies that comprise
it
think of your business users do they
trust the insights that are delivered by
your data platforms
are these insights real time
understanding the data technologies
landscape is obviously fundamental for
data leaders
but not just to maintain technical
parity but also to be able to innovate
and deliver cutting-edge solutions using
these modern data technologies
um if you're a younger organization
there's a good chance that you're
already digital that you're already
cloud native
but if you're a more established
business and maybe
it's been it's been a longer road to
migrate to the cloud and migrate to
modern technologies
you need to start this digital
transformation somewhere where do you
start
choose a department uh choose a team
choose a particular project
to start getting technologies and people
in place the key really is to find that
right use case
and go after it secondly
imagine new experiences with data as i
said before
data is no longer meant as something
just to be analyzed
uh it's it's really uh something that
is meant to lower the barriers for your
users to fuel operational workflows to
deliver superior experiences for your
employees
for your customers the founder of looker
lloyd tab
has a very powerful guiding principle
that says that
great software is an act of empathy and
what this means is it means being
aware of how users use technology today
of what tools you're using today and
meeting them
with data in those tools it means
meeting our workforce and customers
where they already
work and bringing trustworthy data into
the tools that they already use
and they already trust and finally
consider a new role for you
uh data leaders have an amazing
opportunity today to really
influence the direction of their
organizations in very significant ways
every part of an organization that's
going through a digital transformation
is really fueled by data in some way and
data professionals who are
capable of not just solving technology
problems but also solving business
problems
by using data to create new products to
discover new value streams are have
become immensely immensely valuable
and we see this within our own customer
base too all the time
we see data leaders who have
really delivered value to their
organization and have moved on to
business leadership
and really the idea is that data leaders
are positioned to be the business
leaders of our time
so what that means and to say in a very
light-hearted way
is that the data nerds have won data has
been infused into so many moments of our
daily lives
at work at home and these data
experiences are brought to us by data
leaders
yes engineers and analysts but also as i
said data savvy
marketing people sales people product
people
all of them are data nerds and all of
them are data leaders and as i mentioned
we see this
within our own customers we have a lot
of examples of data savvy individuals
who were able to rapidly advance their
careers
because of the value that they created
for their organizations
for their customers through the use of
data um
we can we we have customers folks who
were data analysts
just a few years ago but they became
highly recruitable
and are now in key business leadership
positions at their organizations or
other organizations
so to wrap up i hope you recognize the
enormous opportunity in front of you
today
both for your company but also for your
career data is more valuable than ever
and people who can find a way to lead
with data are in high demand
um we're seeing more demand than ever
from that data hungry workforce and from
a customer base
we see more and more data that's being
generated by an explosion of sas
applications and we continue to see data
infrastructure evolving
and creating new possibilities for using
data in ways that were just
unimaginable not that long ago
so with that i want to thank you for
your time and attention and i invite you
to learn more about looker and engage
with our team so that we can discuss
your data and analytics objectives thank
you